le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
la réunion avec madagascar les autres
îles du sud ouest de l'océan indien fait
partie des trois quarts spot de la
biodiversité mondiale
c'est pour permettre à tous de découvrir
la richesse de sa faune et de sa flore
que le département a mis en place il ya
14 ans le week end nature durant deux
semaines à travers l'île
des animations et visites étaient
proposées pour découvrir pour re
découvrir les espaces naturels sensibles
de lyme
rencontre avec gilles bannier marcel qui
nous font revisiter l'étang saint-paul
le temps d'une matinée
[Musique]
nous allons pendant toute une matinée
découvrir la totalité pourrait s'agir de
la réserve qu habituellement lorsque
l'on fait une visite on découvre par
petit secteur est donc aujourd'hui avec
marcel qui guide conférencier nous
allons explorer ce qu'est la plus grande
zone humide et littorail des
mascareignes
il est 7 heures ce samedi là quand une
quinzaine de marcheurs s'élance de la
chaussée-royale à saint-paul en
direction de la réserve naturelle de
l'étang
il participe à une sortie organisée dans
le cadre des week-ends nature du conseil
départemental fait réel qui a été créée
par
décret ministériel il ya dix ans a pour
but de protéger la plus grande zone
humide littoral des mascareignes qui est
l'étang saint paul
une protection qui va se faire sur 447
ha exactement première étape sur le pont
de grande fontaine un site intéressant
pour l'observation des poules d'eau
l'occasion d'apercevoir une mère et son
petit chose rare pour ce scientifique
voilà du coup vous avez beaucoup de
chance près d'une quarantaine
d'animations pédagogiques étaient
proposés aux amoureux de la nature au
coeur des plus beaux sites de l'île
l'étang saint paul est un lieu propice à
l'observation d'une faune et d'une flore
variées ça fait déjà plusieurs années
que nous faisons cette opération et
chaque année nous essayons du coup du
mauvais de proposer de nouvelles choses
se soient des visites à pied les visites
en kayak des hits à vélo voilà on essaie
chaque année de proposer une nouvelle
activité pour que les gens reviennent et
découvre une nouvelle facette de l'étang
saint paul
[Musique]
c'est en empruntant la route du tour des
roches que le groupe de visiteurs va
rejoindre le moulin à eau
c'est autour de marcel thibault
conférenciers de prendre la parole ici
on est sur le site du moulin à eau ce
moulin appartenait anciennement au 19e
siècle à la famille de launay de la
perrière la roue que nous voyons
actuellement est récente
c'est une copie de l'original qui était
dans un état vraiment qu'ils étaient
très abîmés donc on l'a remplacé il ya à
peu près un peu plus d'une dizaine
d'années maintenant c'est l'occasion
pour les plus jeunes d'en apprendre
davantage sur ces sites oublier enfin
moi je passe je pensé par exemple que
c'était la version originale mais après
ça c'était pas la vraie il n'avait pas
construit ce circuit extrêmement riche
parce que nous sommes là vraiment sur un
territoire qui a qui a assisté aux
origines du peuplement on est vraiment
sur le berceau du peuplement de l'île de
la réunion ancienne île bourbon et on
est à peine à trois kilomètres du vieux
saint paul est donc là on est sur un
territoire extrêmement riche
là point de vue historique et
archéologique également puisqu'on a
encore de nombreuses traces matérielles
la balade se finit dans la forêt
domaniale et sur la passerelle qui relie
cambaie au centre-ville de saint-paul
un point de vue idéal pour apprécier les
arabesques du ski nautique
j'ai appelé des choses par rapport
comment on définit ils nous ont protégés
parce qu'il ya différentes parties dont
il ya des zones qui sont ô sur lesquels
on peut accéder mais
en faisant attention il ya des zones au
contraire qu'ils sont totalement
interdites et c'est important de savoir
pourquoi il ya ça donc moi je veux que
le travail sur le patrimoine c'est
fondamental pour bien comprendre son
histoire et la vie moi j'apprends des
choses à chaque fois que je me promène
et qu'on est en cours explique retour au
parking par le front de mer
l'étang saint-paul reste un lieu unique
à la réunion au milieu de la ville son
écosystème est fragile ce week-end
nature ou pour but de sensibiliser les
réunionnais c'est très important pour le
département de protéger les milieux
naturels les espaces naturels sensibles
pourquoi parce qu'à la réunion nous
avons la chance d'avoir une biodiversité
extraordinaire il faut aujourd'hui
protéger cette biodiversité qui est
connu mondialement et qui est
malheureusement très fragile et donc
menacés chaque année au mois d'octobre
le département propose de nombreuses
sorties gratuites pour découvrir l'île
sous différents aspects 2018 était la
14e édition des week-ends nature
[Musique]
organisée chaque année par le
département les week-ends de nature ont
pour objectif de sensibiliser le public
sur la biodiversité de l'île en faisant
découvrir sous un autre aspect ces
espaces naturels sensibles
les agents permettent ainsi de mieux les
protéger avec comme thème cette année
nature et sports l'événement propose des
activités à travers toute l'île comme le
cheval le vtt ou encore des nuits à la
belle étoile
pour plus de renseignements rendez vous
sur le site du département au
www.defirh.fr 4 point fr lien social
accompagne les réunionnais pour la
mobilité
je m'appelle simaïeva date j'avais 21
ans vient de s'étendre et de la réunion
et je suis ici pour me former en
boucherie à marseille après mon bac en
2014 mais je suis tout de suite inscrit
au cnam je suis pas eu de billet à payer
et tous les mois j'ai reçu un complément
de salaire et même de avec le cnam j'ai
eu l'aide à l'installation est ici comme
il ya nos réseaux de viande on est dans
l'europe il ya plus de marchandises plus
de choix je préférais faire ma formation
ici je suis ici je travaille
personnellement je n'en ressens grandi
j'ai un bagage maintenant je peux
travailler partout l'état pas pressés de
retourner à la réunion à terme d'ouvrir
ma propre boucherie boucherie bada
[Musique]